[Applaudissements]
dans sa maison en banlieue de Kiev
Karina est de nouveau sans électricité
alors elle doit lancer son générateur
j'ai beaucoup de chance j'ai pu acheter
un groupe électrogène il y a deux ans de
nos jours ils sont beaucoup trop cher
avec un litre d'essence à environ 1000
grivesna soit 25 euros c'est parti pour
une heure de courant le temps pour
Karina de voir le discours du président
ukrainien vaut le dîner ski devant le
Congrès américain
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment historique ils ont vu un
président infatigable qui n'a pas quitté
son pays depuis le début de la guerre
ils ont vu un homme sûr de lui qui se
bat pour nous pour l'Ukraine et les
Ukrainiens
pour Carina et sa mère ce combat est
très concret une fois l'essence dans le
générateur consommé il n'y a de nouveau
plus de lumière
les coupures de courant sont
complètement imprévisibles nous ne
savons jamais ce que Poutine et les
soldats russes ont prévus quand il n'y a
pas d'électricité il n'y a rien la pompe
à eau a besoin d'électricité pour
fonctionner la chaudière à gaz a
également besoin d'électricité
nous ne pouvons rien faire
nous sommes complètement impuissants
mais même dans ces conditions Karina et
sa mère ne se laissent pas abattre
c'est beaucoup plus dur pour ceux qui
sont à l'étranger en ce moment
pourvu que l'Occident ne les abandonne
pas
alors le message de vous le dire
Zelinski elles espèrent que le Congrès
l'a reçu 5 sur 5